hey you two give me a sec
follow the hero thing in the plaza me
I've got a date with whoever's behind
this to be a short day
destiny too tells a brand-new story what
happens when a world full of superheroes
loses their powers their history and a
home since deci one release there's been
no phone they could stand before and not
tip over whether it's crota oryx spider
monsters whatever but in the opening of
dusty two players realized there is in
fact a foe who has the power to not only
take everything you own to take your
power away
or
dominus Gaul is a cabal warlord who has
brought with him the red Legion and has
come to our system to take the travelers
powers the light take it for himself
goals jealous he wants to have the light
he wants to be chosen Gaul is a
different villain he's not a psychopath
who just wants to race Madden off the
face of the earth he feels like this is
something that is oh damn because of
everything he's been through he's a
villain who you're like yeah this guy
kind of has a stuff together he's more
like uh Alan Rickman's character from
die hard like - all the Britishness the
protector itself the traveler is put in
a cage and in an instance all Guardians
lose their lives unexpected and
irreversible you can no longer go back
to the tower you can no longer even walk
all you can do is stumble nobody
expected that light could be taken away
once it was given city has been lost and
the Vanguard's be cast out and you are
the hero this story whether you're a
Titan a warlock or hunter you have to go
out and get your powers back and take
back this signal
[Music]
whether you're playing destiny today or
it's going to be your first foray into
the franchise destiny to is a new
adventure for everyone
it's a fresh start for all
destiny too has an all new cinematic
campaign there's more cinematics than
we've ever had before how long before
the fleets come back with that more
story missions
[Music]
there's requesters adventured start
you're gonna be people talking to you
let's bring them home you and I all new
worlds to explore
we've got cooperative strikes for three
players new nightfall strikes and a
brand new raid
in destiny - we built you all new
weapons all new armor and a pile of
brand new exotics
we also redesigned the weapon slot
they're gonna have a kinetic weapon an
energy weapon and then a power weapon
power weapons are things like fusion
rifles and sniper rifles and grenade
launcher in that energy slot and the
kinetic slot you can have the same
weapons
the new weapon plan was designed to
provide players with more freedom more
choice use the stuff that they love
each character has these new supers and
they're really changing the way it feels
to play the game we have the dawn blade
you can cast your super you've got your
sword
and you're flying over everyone and you
can just rain down fire Phoenix
projectiles that just decimate people
many of the sandal
a sentinel is a Titan and he is able to
summon a shield that he could just knock
his opponents out with breaking through
his shield can't just bang it off dudes
heads
[Music]
then you have the arc Strider
they summon this mystical staff and
wield it like a crazy Acrobat cracking
enemies in the head it's awesome
[Music]
the idea of losing your home and being
cast out and the lengths that you go to
to get it back it's all tied together to
be something that's really meaningful
sense of starting as an underdog and
climbing to great height it's really fun
sd2 is the place where we get to reach
back out to everyone who could enjoy a
sweet first-person shooter in a future
world with giant awesome aliens
and geard chase and powers to use and
say come chick has world out come get
invested in running the story
[Music]
you